hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming true with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video we're going to talk about is
the mean value theorem so what is the
mean value theorem how to understand it
and then we're going to go through an
example so let's get right into it the
mean value theorem tells us that if F is
continuous on the closed interval a B so
if a functions continuous on the closed
interval a B and it's differentiable on
the open interval A to B then there
exists a number C okay in the interval a
B such that F prime of C equals F of B
minus F of a over B minus a so that's a
mouthful so let's see if we can kind of
a break it down and see what it's
referring to here so when they say that
the function is continuous that just
means that there's no breaks in the
graph okay so you're not picking up your
pen or your pencil it's just a
continuous graph differentiable what
that tells us is that you know that the
curve you can find the derivative at any
point along the curve it's smooth okay
and then the last part just says that
there's a an x coordinate okay a C value
that's in between the two endpoints ANB
such that the slope so when you take the
derivative that's referring to the slope
okay at that C value at that point is
the same as the average rate of change
between the two end points let me show
you on the graph what we're looking at
here okay just a sample okay so say for
example the graph looks like this
alright and this point here is a and
this point over here is B okay so right
here's a and right here's point B okay
so this point here is going to be a
comma F of a this point is going to be B
comma F of B okay and so what this is
saying is there has to be at you know at
least one C value in between a and B
okay where the slope of the tangent line
is the same as the slope okay because
this is the average rate of change K y2
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 as the average
rate of change between these two end
points so when you talk about the
average rate of change you're talking
about the slope and you can see right
over here at
this point approximately that tangent
line has the same slope as the slope
between the two end points and also over
here the slope of that tangent line has
the same slope as the slope between the
two end points so in this case you'd
have two C values so right here we'll
say C sub one and right here we'll say C
sub two sorry you're with me so far
let's look at an example and I think
it'll get a little bit clearer so on
this one here they tell us that the
function is X cubed plus 4x and we're
looking at the interval from negative 1
to 1 so first of all we want to see does
the mean value theorem apply so first
thing is the function continuous well we
could graph it okay or we could do it on
our graphing calculator but we know this
is a polynomial and we know polynomials
are continuous they don't have any
breaks in them okay then the next part
is is it differentiable meaning can we
take the derivative you know in between
these two endpoints along this curve
well we know polynomials are smooth
there's no corners there's no cusps
nothing like that so we know that we be
able to take the derivative along this
curve at any point as well as in between
negative 1 and 1
and then the last part is there must be
a sea value in between negative 1 and 1
where that instantaneous rate of change
okay which is the slope of the tangent
line is the same as the average rate of
change between the two end points so
let's go ahead and analyze this so we're
gonna put in negative 1 into our
function so f of negative 1 equals
negative 1 cubed plus 4 times negative 1
and F of positive 1 equals 1 cubed plus
4 times 1 so this is 1 plus 4 is 5 and
this is let's see negative 1 minus 4
which is negative 5 so our two end
points look like they're negative 1 and
negative 5 and we've got positive 1 and
positive 5 all right so now we can go on
to do is find the point that's in
between negative 1 and 1 that has the
same slope between these two points so
let's go ahead and find the slope so
we're going to do the slope formula y2
minus y1 okay so 5 minus negative 5 over
x2 minus x1 one minus negative one so
that comes out to ten over two which
equals five so that means that somewhere
in between negative one and one the
slope of the tangent line must be five
so let's go ahead and take the
derivative so f prime of x equals three
x squared plus four and that must be
equal to the average rate of change five
so if we solve this equation here I'm
going to subtract 4 from both sides
divide both sides by 3 take the square
root of both sides so square root of x
squared and the square root of 1/3 that
gives us plus or minus let me take a
screw to both side so you get 1 over
square root of 3 or if you rationalize
you get plus or minus square root 3 over
3 now just to show you if we graph this
the graph looks something like this ok
and you can graph it on your calculator
to see that a little bit more clearly
but basically we have the two endpoints
negative 1 negative 5 that's down here
positive 1 positive 5 that's up here and
if you look at the slope okay of the
line see if I can do this here more
accurately likes like that and the slope
of the line through the two endpoints in
between negative 1 and positive 1 there
has to be a point where the
instantaneous rate of change say like
right there is the same as the average
rate of change so same thing like right
about there and those are going to be
these two points here at negative square
root 3 over 3 and positive square root 3
over 3 that instantaneous rate of change
is the same as the average rate of
change so I hope this cleared up how to
work with mean value theorem a little
bit better
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my past videos and I look forward to
helping you in the future ones I'll talk
to you soon